aujourd'hui on inaugurait l'incubateur
pépinière hôtel d'entreprises ici c'est
vraiment un lieu qui est dédié à
l'innovation et l'entrepreneuriat c'est
un lieu qui est pour les start up pour
les entrepreneurs et c'est un lieu qui
va les connecter à tout l'écosystème de
paris-saclay les grands pôles académique
à l'institut polytechnique de paris
l'université paris saclay les grands
comptes comme comme edf comme servier
comme thales qui ont alors leur r&d à
paris saclay ya plus de 100 startups qui
sortent chaque année des laboratoires
des des rangs des étudiants de paris
saclay et sont souvent des start up qui
sont liées à la technologie et à la
recherche du plateau et donc ses projets
d'entreprises ces innovations ont besoin
d'être connecté à ce cluster à ce pouce
aux grands pôles d'innovation pour
continuer à grandir faut créer des
emplois pour créer de la richesse avec
l'incubateur pépinière hôtel
d'entreprises ont créé un lieu pour ces
projets vraiment au coeur du réacteur
ici et donc c'est un lieu qui va être
animée qui va proposer des services qui
va vraiment être un lieu partenariale
dans lequel on va chercher à impliquer
tout l'écosystème de paris-saclay alors
il ya une équipe qui est en charge de ce
projet qui a été désignée après une
consultation après un concours et donc
c'est bouygues bâtiment ile-de-france
qui construit le bâtiment c'est la
caisse des dépôts et consignations la
banque de territoire avec des
partenaires privés qui est investisseurs
et puis côté exploitation
il ya donc stop and work est une filiale
de regus et créativallée est donc cette
équipe là
pour mission d'apporter les meilleurs
services pour les stars tupper vraiment
des conditions de travail à des
standards internationaux de mener des
actions d'animation de mise en
visibilité de cet écosystème à l'échelle
internationale avec des partenariats un
peu avec les grands pôles d'innovation
dans le monde
c'est vraiment un projet qui est né sous
une belle étoile et qui est vraiment un
projet partenarial et qui va le rester
il est fait pour créer du lien pour
créer plus de visibilité pour créer plus
de partenariats entre l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'innovation et
l'entreprenariat de paris saclay
[Musique]